Jim shooter is considered by many to be
the most reviled man to ever work at
Marvel Comics so much so that his own
staff revolted against him and then
burned him in effigy but to hear Jim
shooter tell it he was never fired
because of the things that he did at
Marvel Comics he was fired because he
blew the whistle on corruption with
Marvel
Executives let's talk about this so as
we get into this we need to take a step
back to the time before Jim shoter was
brought on as editor and chief even
hired by Marvel and we need to talk
about a guy named Sheldon fineberg so in
the same way that Disney owns Marvel
right now Marvel had previously been
owned by a company called magazine
Management Incorporated that was created
by a guy named Martin Goodman Martin
Goodman sold everything to a guy named
Martin akran who ran a company called
Perfect film and chemical eventually
Martin arriman is ousted as CEO and he's
replaced by Sheldon fineberg now Sheldon
Feinberg sits down takes one look at
Marvel realizes how financially
insolvent that company is so he brings
in a guy named Al landow and he tells Al
your job as the new president of Marvel
taking over for Stan Lee who basically
took off to Hollywood to form what you
and I now car Marvel Studios your job
Alando is to get Marvel back to a state
of financial solvency but it turned out
Al landow was cooking the books he was
lying to Sheldon Feinberg about how much
money Marvel was making so Sheldon
Feinberg fires Al landow he brings in
Jim gton and Sheldon and Jim sit down
with Stan Le and anybody else with
decision- making Authority Under them
and says get it together or the entire
company gets shut down and sold so what
led to these Financial issues that
Marvel was dealing with and how did they
tie into JY shooter so Marvel's
financial problems stemmed from a
variety of different places but Chief
among them was how Marvel was running
its company one of the things to
understand is that Comics as they were
sold back then were largely done through
news stands malt shops convenience
stores places where people would either
buy periodicals or where young people
would congregate and hang out or were
most likely to visit you did have your
occasional comic book store but it
wasn't nearly what it is right now the
reason why this is so important is
because when Marvel creates a comic book
that comic is written by the writer and
it's drawn by the artist then it's sent
off to a letterer the person who puts
the letters into the speech bubbles and
the colorist the person that fills in
all the colors then it's sent off to the
printers and then it's sent to its
destination
where it just awaits to be purchased the
way in which Marvel got comics from
point A to point B was a company called
Curtis circulation Curtis circulation
was their distributor the problem is
that Curtis circulation ultimately ended
up going belly up and so Marvel had to
go to another company called Independent
News in order to get their Comics
shipped from the printers to their
destinations Independent News was one of
three companies that merged together
National Allied and All-American being
the other two which formed DC Comics
Marvel had to go to its competitor and
ask its competitor to ship their comics
for them now all this happened under the
original owner Martin Goodman but the
fact remains that of course DC did what
you would expect them to do they limited
the number of comics they were willing
to ship for Marvel specifically that
number was eight that comes off the
heels of the first collapse of the comic
book industry at the end of World War II
when superheroes stopped being popular
and the second collapse of the comic
book industry in the mid1 1950s when a
guy named Frederick Wortham published a
book called seduction of the innocent
which convinced a good portion of the
American public that comic books were
corrupting kits but focusing on the
chief reason why Marvel was struggling
financially most of it had to do with
late fees and it was all due to how
writers and artists were handling things
within the company the reality here is
that even when a comic is effectively
finished and is sent to the printers
there are deadlines there if those
deadlines are not met fees are incurred
the way in which Marvel functioned at
that point in time is that it was
basically a Clubhouse DC Comics was very
professional you wore a tie you wore a
button-up shirt it was very much down to
business Marvel had balloons hanging
from the ceilings sword fights in the
hallways with toy swords guys who were
sleeping under their desks because they
didn't actually have a place to live
because downtown New York was so
expensive and so with Marvel operating
as a frat house and creatives basically
running the show a lot of it just kind
of came down to writing comics and
drawing Comics at times that worked best
for for them now you would think that
the editors and chief at that point in
time would keep all that sorted out but
the reality here is that when Stan Lee
left the role of editor-in Chief went to
become president at Marvel stepped down
from that role and took off to Hollywood
he was succeeded by a handful of other
people and in no particular order these
guys were Roy Thomas Marv Wolfman Jerry
Conway Archie Goodwin Len wine the issue
here is that these guys didn't really
want to be editors and chief once they
got the job what they realize is they
just wanted to cre create comic books
the kicker about all this is that if a
person became an editor and Chief and
then stepped down from that role they
got to enjoy something called the writer
editor role what it meant is they have
no oversight for those of you guys who
were unfamiliar with how editors work
say for example that I'm writing an
X-Men comic and in that comic book I
want to have a story where Spider-Man
teams up with the X-Men to defeat
Magneto my editor will go to the editor
of Spider-Man and say what's Spider-Man
doing right now and that editor will say
Spider-Man's INSP space with the
Guardians of the Galaxy so my editor
will come back to me and say you can't
have Spider-Man in your story because
he's supposed to be out there in space
it wouldn't make any sense for him to
suddenly appear on Earth that's called
continuity with the writer editors and
even other people who didn't enjoy the
writer editor role this continuity
seemingly didn't have any bearing they
just wanted to write the stories that
they wanted to write and didn't really
concern themselves with what anybody
else was doing St notop to say everybody
was doing that there were certainly
instances of writers following
continuity but by and large this was a
major issue built on top of that comic
books were late all the time so you
might get the first issue of a comic in
January you might not get the second
until March and so with all these fees
and this just inefficiency of the
company operating the way that it was
this is the reason why when Sheldon
fineberg came in and eventually brought
Jim gson in they said get it together or
get it shut down now let's talk about
Jim shooter so something to understand
here is that Jim shooter was basically a
child prodigy at 13 years old he was
recovering from surgery during that
point in time he started reading Marvel
Comics and DC Comics and so what he did
is he started sending off scripts for
super boy in the Legion of Superheroes
to a guy named Mort weissinger what Mort
Weiss singer did as the editor of
everything related to Superman and the
reason why the silver AG of Superman was
so popular Mort we singer brought Jim
shooter on and then not only had him
writing scripts for Comics but had him
proofreading and editing the scripts for
Comics that had been written by people
who had been in the industry for 20
years keeping in mind he's 14 years old
at this point in time the issue is that
Jim shooter did not like the management
style of more weissinger which is
interesting because he actually adopted
that management style when he worked for
Marvel but we'll get to that here in a
minute but for Jim shooter himself
because of the fact that the money that
he was expecting to make he wasn't
really making and because he wasn't
really getting the notoriety he hoped to
get he ultimately quit now fast forward
to Marv Wolfman operating as editor-in
Chief at Marvel Comics Marv Wolfman was
barely holding the company together and
he sent a few guys to go and find Jim
shooter because word had reached his
ears about how capable Jim shooter was
Jim's brought in as a proof reader then
an assistant editor and then an editor
this guy's job was to do exactly what he
did at DC Comics to proofread the
scripts being written by writers this
led to Jim shooter earning the name
troubleshooter because he would look
over these scripts operating as an
editor without actually being called an
editor and say this ending sucks go back
and rewrite it this is not in continuity
go back and fix it over and over and
over again now as you guys can probably
imagine when it comes to creative types
they want to kind of create with a lot
of freedom not really have any
restriction on them with Jim shooter he
was the opposite now Jim shooter because
of his capabilities working as a proof
reader and an assistant editor made his
way up the ranks to becoming an editor
but by this point in time Marv Wolfman
had long since left the role of
editor-in Chief Jerry Conway followed
him lasted about a month and then Archie
Goodwin took his place but Archie
Goodwin's role as editor-in-chief as he
explained it to Stan Lee was temporary
he only wanted the role until Stan Lee
could find somebody else but by this
point in time Sheldon Feinberg and Jim
gton had showed up to Stan Lee and said
get it together or get laid off
everything that you're building in
Hollywood is going to be gone sold off
to whoever it is that wants to buy it
and so Stan Lee looking at Marvel as a
whole and seeing how effective Jim
shooter was sat down with a meeting and
said do you want to become the new
editor-in-chief Jim shooter said yes now
Jim Shooter's time as editor-in-chief is
marked by some of the greatest
achievements in modern history with
regards to the comic book industry but
one of the most reviled Moments by
writers and artists across the board and
here's what I mean by that when Jim
shooter came on as editor-in Chief and
to hear John Burns say it Jim shooter
was great for the first two to three
years but he just stayed on too long Jim
shooter got that ship right like that he
basically adopted the mort wi singer
style if you're late on your scripts
you're fired if you're late on your
artwork you're fired if you disagree
with me you're fired there's my way or
the highway because this is Marvel we
have some of the most popular titles
currently being written Uncanny X-Men by
that point in time was more popular than
Superman and so the reality here is the
line of people who want to write and
draw for Marvel stretches out the front
door and around the building twice so
get with the program or or get out this
led to Marvel losing some of its top
writers and artists John burn Jean colen
Jerry Conway Roy Thomas Frank Miller all
these guys were fed up with Jim shooter
for a variety of reasons most of these
had to do with the fact that Jim shooter
would change the work of people a really
good example of this is during Uncanny
X-Men with the dark Phoenix Saga and in
fact this is probably the most popular
example as a lot of you guys probably
know the Phoenix and dark Phoenix
stories are the stories where Jee gray
achieved Godly levels of power she went
from being this Damsel in Distress under
the old X-Men stories from Stan Lee Jack
Kirby Gary Friedrich Roy Thomas Arnold
Drake to becoming this Godly powerful
character under Chris Claremont but at
the end of the dark Phoenix Saga because
her actions had led to her destroying an
entire star system basically killing
billions of people that she was going to
serve a kind of prison sentence for her
crimes and then be let go the response
to Jim shooter was no that's not going
to happen she needs to endure just
corporal punishment whipping to the
point where her skins flayed off just
this really really really dark stuff and
so Chris Claremont and John burn sit
down together and they basically say if
that's the game that he wants to play
we're not playing it he's done it with
other people we're writing and drawing
the hottest selling comic on the market
right now we can do whatever we want so
they go to Jim shooter and they say if
you don't let us tell the story that we
want to tell with Jean Gray then we're
just going to kill her character the
response to Jim shooter perfect do it
now it was a bluff But ultimately jimm
shooter called it and despite the
protest of Chris Claremont and John burn
jym Shooter's response no kill the
character now if you look up interviews
from Chris Claremont at the time that
happened or with even a few years of
that happening he would swear up and
down the gym Shooters one of the worst
people to ever work at Marvel but there
was a recent interview that came out in
a documentary on Amazon called Chris
claremont's X-Men where he sits down and
says it was actually the right call to
make and it was because it elevated J
Gray's popul ity in a way that just
couldn't have been done otherwise but
these were the kind of changes that Jim
shooter was making Banning any
depictions of homosexuality in comics
any aggressive depictions of any kind of
physical intimacy between characters a
lot of this was rooted in the fact that
Jim shooter believed in the comics code
Authority but the fact remains writers
and artists were frustrated because Jim
shooter was changing their work without
their knowledge or forcing them to
change it despite the fact that they
never saw a problem with it on the other
side Jim shooter probably did more to
improve the lot for comic book writers
and artists than anybody before him he
expanded royalties for comic book
writers and artists so they were making
more money per comic than they had
before he became Editor in Chief that he
worked alongside a guy by the name of
Phil suing who's Phil suing Phil seing
was like an English teacher or a gym
teacher or something like that but
because Marvel Comics was selling their
Comics through news stands M shops
convenience stores things like that Phil
seing had an idea where he said when you
sell your Comics to new stands they pay
wholesale price a fraction of the cost
so if a comic costs a dollar for you and
me to buy using arbitrary numbers a
wholesaler might pay like 50 cents or 4
cents the downside to this and the
nature of the business model was that if
any one of these stores purchased like a
100 issues of Spider-Man but they only
sold 50 they could send the other 50
back for a refund on their wholesale
price or they could tear the cover off
and because it's a damaged comic they
send it back for more than the wholesale
price but a discounted price based on
what the consumer would purchase they
were ripping Marvel off Phil seing had
pitched an idea to Roy Thomas that
didn't come to fruition until he spoke
with Jim shooter the idea is that Phil
seing and people like him would buy
comics from Marvel at a wholesale price
but whatever Comics they didn't sell
they would just be stuck with this led
to the direct market and the eventual
comic book store Jim shooter was one of
the guys that helped to make this happen
because of things like this Jim shooter
changed the comic book industry in a lot
of positive ways not just for writers
and artists but also for the consumer
but at the end of the day the strict way
in which he was running Marvel ran off
writers and artists and pissed off the
writers and artists who stayed there and
so as we mentioned in the intro John
burn held a barbecue at his house bunch
of writers and artists showed up they
took a doll stuffed it with copies of a
comic called new universe and then put
Jim shooter's face on it and burned it
in effigy here's the kicker to all of
this Jim shooter would argue that none
of that was the reason for why he got
fired that what Jim shooter did is he
went to the CEO of New World
entertainment the movie studio based out
of Hollywood why because by this point
in time Perfect film and Chemical
Corporation had been rebranded to
Cadence Industries but what Jim shooter
claims to have realized is that the
upper management Sheldon fineberg Jim
gton and those guys were using Marvel
Comics as a way to lay off business
expenses for any of the other
subsidiaries of cadence Industries what
it did is it gave the illusion that
Marvel was worth less money than it was
and so Sheldon fineberg Jim gton and
those guys sold Marvel Comics to New
World pictures but they sold it for
something like $45 million but because
of how Marvel Comics appeared
shareholders got a pittance of what the
shares were actually worth something
like $17 and the rest of the money was
pocketed by Marvel's upper management
According to Jim shooter he went to the
new world picture CEO Bob ream and said
here's what's going on this is a problem
but because he bypassed the upper
management at Marvel and went directly
to the CEO the upper management fired
him on the spot and to hear Jim shooter
tell it he had a meeting with Bob and
Bob's response yes we know you're right
but the reality here is we just bought
Marvel Comics we can't fire upper
management what would the shareholders
think now how much of that is true I
don't entirely know but that's
supposedly the story of Jim shooter was
canned from Marvel Comics that it had
nothing to do with how he was treating
the comic book staff writers artists and
the strict adherence to the rules that
he was creating supposedly it had
everything to do with the fact that he
blew the whistle on corruption at the
upper levels of Marvel management with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end let me know what
you think about videos like this and I
will catch you all later peace